bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
dans ça vous regarde au sommaire ce soir
le ps qui dit oui à l'union des gauches
alors faut-il y voir une résurrection ou
au contraire une soumission à l efi le
ps at il enfin trancher entre ces deux
gauches irréconciliables on en débat ce
soir avec nos invités et le
réchauffement climatique dans tout cela
ces morts on ne va pas y arriver est
lancé il ya quelques jours notre invité
françois gemenne membre du giec est
conseillé de yannick jadot pendant la
campagne présidentielle alors quand
ont-ils par là at il vraiment renoncé à
ce combat enfin nous a franchi ce soir l
amont d'un gars va nous dira ce qu'il
faut retenir des toutes premières
investitures aux législatives dans la
majorité présidentielle
un peu d'histoire avec brandon loyrette
qui nous décryptera les signaux
politiques que les présidents élus ont
voulu envoyer en nommant leur tout
premier premier ministre
enfin delphine sabattier nous parlera
d'un projet d'appli du gouvernement pour
valider notre identité en ligne voilà
pour le sommaire c'est parti pour ce
manga rld
[Musique]
jeudi si vous pensez que vous
n'appartenez plus à l'espace commun de
la gauche
si vous pensez que votre avenir est
plutôt avec emmanuel macron
mais très bien si vous tu veux clarifier
des positions
mais je vais aller jusqu'au bout
accent du sud ouest voilà donc pour
l'ambiance hier soir au conseil national
du parti socialiste alors est-ce que
l'accord validé hier par le ps marque un
nouveau départ pour le parti socialiste
ou au contraire sa mort politique et la
trahison de ses valeurs pour en débattre
nous sommes ce soir avec corinne
narassiguin bonsoir vous êtes la numéro
deux du parti socialiste et puis vous
avez surtout participer directement à
ces négociations avec la france et
insoumise et vous soutenez évidemment
cet accord à mes côtés également roland
cayrol bonsoir vous êtes politologue
chercheur honoraire au cevipof et
également christophe barbier dont 120
journalistes éditorialistes et directeur
de la rédaction du magazine francs
tireurs alors la gauche at elle ouvert
une nouvelle page de son histoire avec
cet accord validé par le ps hier
stéphane blakowski va nous aider à y
voir plus clair
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane fortement bonsoir à
toutes et à tous alors si j'ai bien
compris stéphane si j'ai bien compris
chapeau mélenchon là faut reconnaître
que mélenchon est très fort voire même
très très fort en 2008 quand il a quitté
le ps je vous rappelle qu'il avait fait
moins de 20% au congrès de reims en tant
que dernier congrès quinze ans plus tard
les socialistes ont à nouveau voté et là
à 60% c'est qui le patron c'est
mélenchon en écoute la responsabilité
lourde que jean luc mélenchon prend ce
soir si qu'il est maintenant celui qui
va porter les espoirs de toute la gauche
et les écologistes
il est le chef de la plus grosse force à
ce titre parce que nous sommes des
républicains des démocrates nous
considérons que il lui appartient à lui
d'être appelés à matignon donc là on
sent bien que c'est un petit peu de
mettre la pression mélenchon moi ce que
j'ai entendu là c'est alors si bien sûr
jean luc mélenchon n'est pas élu premier
ministre ça sera tout sa faute et là
forcément faudra qu'ils rendent des
comptes en attendant voyage quand on
regarde la répartition de vos mecs qui
tueront world a un qui est le patron
donc plus de 300 investiture pour la
france insoumise en deuxième position
les écologistes et où sont les
socialistes ah oui regardez ils sont là
avec 70 sièges investiture mais ça
m'aurait permet de créer un groupe que
de faire de la politique pendant cinq
ans à l'assemblée ce vote d'hier soir il
a tenu à montrer des divisions
importantes au sein du ps or les
divisions internes au sein du ps ses
côtés l'adn du parti c'est s'est ancrée
profondément dans la tradition parce
qu'on parle comme d'un parti qui
réunissent un moment mélenchon et
d'escadrons voyez ils en ont vu d'autres
sauf que là quand même entre les 40% qui
ne veulent pas le scrutin mélenchon et
les 60% qui veulent bien le soutenir
vont-ils pouvoir se réconcilier et alors
votre pronostic homo je ne sais trop
rien vous savez que c'est très compliqué
le ps le culte de la division à très
loin à ce que même parmi les 40 % qui
sont divisés il ya encore des divisions
chacun suit un peu sa stratégie alors il
ya ceux qui n'ont pas l'intention
quitter le navire la stratégie c'est un
peu on attend que mélenchon se plante
législatives et après on va régler nos
comptes au congrès ça c'est un peu le
canal historique
labeaume mme palin thank you
comment dire d'abandonner le parti
socialiste nous nous y restons pour le
faire changer et nous comptons bien
après cette période il y aura un congrès
c'est là où nous essaierons de reprendre
la même parce que nous pensons que le
parti socialiste doit être d'une partie
gouvernement et poèmes parti qui suit la
radicalité à tout crin donc il ya ceux
qui disent attention rendez vous au
congrès pierre il ya c'est que quand
même l'intention de présenter des
candidatures on pense bien sûr à carole
delga qui déjà dit qu'elle le ferait en
occitanie sauf que dans ce que l'accord
que des socialistes ont signé avec
mélenchon il est prévu d exclure les
dissidents ce qui même dans les statuts
du parti socialiste
encore mieux alors dans ce cas on va
exclure carole delga excusez-moi
président de la région aquitaine et la
présidente de région la mieux réélu de
france est-ce qu'on va aller jusque là
donc dans ce cas il faudrait créer un
nouveau deux parties et là vous pensez
bien quelques très grands stratèges qui
réfléchit ça on écoute qu'il faut une
refondation profonde du parti socialiste
il faut une nouvelle formation qui
pourrait s'appeler autrement que parti
socialiste promet un débat faut-il
garder le nom socialiste ou pas bon
c'est pas le sujet important il doit
s'inspirer du spd en allemagne c'est à
dire un parti à la fois populaire et
social démocrate c'est sain l'avenir de
notre famille politique
voilà est-ce qu'il faut appeler ce
nouveau parti socialiste c'est ce que
mots doit y être est ce qu'il faut
mettre le mot éléphants dans le nom du
nouveau parti également une infection
and honey là dessus on sait confiance à
corbas comme des régionales qui regarde
ça de très près c'est la république en
marche ah bah oui dire que pour
l'instant il était occupé toute la
semaine à recruter donc les nerfs que
sarkozy leur a dit d'aller voir ces gars
là on va où ses fils et fille là et on
va pouvoir les embaucher et hop voilà
des socialistes arrivent sur le marché
bat pas de problème no problemo
bienvenue les socialistes surtout que si
vous allez à la république en marche
vous allez retrouver vos anciens
collègues
moi aussi j'étais membre du parti
socialiste quand je vois que le parti
socialiste a abandonné tout simplement
l'ambition d'être un parti de
gouvernement à renier ses convictions
pour quelques circonscriptions alors je
dis oui rejoignez-nous aux
sociaux-démocrates et les insoumis dans
tout ça mais vous savez chez les
insoumis monde déteste l'arrogance ou le
rôle alors qu'est-ce qu'on n'aime pas
l'arrogance bon mais là forcément c'est
un peu de temps en temps de se moquer
des perdants donc on écoute alexis
corbière cac dérape et
checa se dire je crois que son grand
départ du parti socialiste a à peu près
autant d'effet que la disparition de
l'horloge parlante pas je veux dire
franchement il ya peu de gens qui savent
encore que ça existait les nostalgiques
de l'horloge parlante apprécieront enfin
on va pas réduire ça à cette petit coup
de pied de l'âne d'alexis corbières on
prend quand même qu'il ya comme toute
une nouvelle génération qu'on fait de la
politique avec mélenchon et qu'il a
effectivement voir enfin se concrétiser
ce pourquoi ils se sont battus et ça
leur fait très plaisir on les comprend
quand on est de gauche au soir du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle on était surpris de la
force du résultat de jean luc mélenchon
et en même temps pour le second tour on
avait un peu la gueule de bois eh bien
je dis à tous ces électeurs là revenait
au mois de juin si vous revenez tous
dans les urnes on peut être au second
tour dans 470 circonscription c'est
énorme c'est plus des quatre cinquièmes
des circonscriptions du pays et on peut
emporter une majorité donc demain et
mélenchon bond sur scène pour fêter son
triomphe mais attention pas d'arrogance
surtout pas d'arrogance merci beaucoup
stéphane blakowski corinne narassiguin
est-ce que vous partager cet
enthousiasme de manon aubry là qu'on
vient de voir nous on en est un dans une
logique plus raisonnée et raisonnable je
crois c'est forcément un chemin un
cheminement il ya eu des réflexions
c'est un risque qu'on a pris on le prend
en conscience on c'est un pari qu'on
fait au parti socialiste avec le reste
de quoi avec avec olivier faure mais
justement il ya des ruptures possible tu
vas faire voter au
sein du parti socialiste je crois qu'en
réalité
comme souvent peut-être les l'hérault la
représentation nationale n'est pas
complètement totalement le reflet de ce
qu'on ressent sur le terrain et des
militants je pense qu'on a plus que 60%
des militants qui sont avec nous dans
dans ce dans cette aventure en fait
parce que c'est ça reste un pari on sait
pas encore exactement comment tout ça va
se dessiner on va on va construire en
marchant en avançant et mais je crois
que nous sommes nous sommes nous
avançons avec la conviction que c'est le
meilleur chemin que choisir lé isolement
c'était là justement signé la fin du
parti socialiste comme un parti qui peut
encore peser au niveau national et qui
se replient vers un socialisme municipal
pour longtemps et donc c'est ça que nous
refusons aussi c'est de pouvoir peser
dans le débat national comment comment
il faut interpréter politiquement cet
accord est-ce que c'est enfin la
clarification entre les deux gauches
irréconciliables est ce que ça veut dire
que le ps a tranché oui je crois que
c'est c'est une façon pour nous
d'affirmer ça avec olivier faure en
réalité ça fait plus de quatre ans qu'on
le dit depuis de legault le congrès qui
a suivi les élections présidentielles de
2017 avec olivier faure nous sommes dans
cette idée que la meilleure façon de
réaffirmer l'identité socialiste et est
d'être capable d'affirmer aussi sa
capacité à être dans certains des
rassemblements larges de la gauche n'est
pas dépassements dans le rassemblement
il ya au contraire un dépassement dans
lequel on s'affirme ç'a toujours été
l'histoire du parti socialiste de faire
partie de souvent même de mener des
rassemblements qui mène à la victoire et
c'est avec ça qu'il fallait renouer le
fait qu'on dise qu'il ya pas de gauches
irréconciliables vrai c'est pas le parti
socialiste qui mène au rassemblement
bien sûr parce qu'il ya il ya une
réalité qui est celle de l'élection
présidentielle et et c'est aussi ça
d'être un parti de gouvernement
justement c'est un parti qui accepte de
se confronter à la réalité et de faire
des choix aussi parfois qu'ils sont très
pragmatiques et pour pouvoir avancer
parce que pour aller comme le disais je
reste pour les verrines et a dû
commencer par le réel roland cayrol
est-ce que à vos yeux
ps ton de 2 le dos à la social
démocratie avec cet accord écoutez
l'impression que on comprend pourquoi
ils ont fait ça et vous l'avez très bien
expliqué et en même temps ça donne une
impression un peu de mal à l'aise dans
cette technique de on échange des
convictions
contre des plat de lentilles ce à quoi
les parties françaises notamment le
parti socialiste sont habitués en
interne pour les congrès ont fait comme
ça c'est à dire pour vous c'est un
accord électoral
sur le fond il n'y a pas de de vrais
choix pour le moment c'est un accord
électoral et législatif jeu j'irais même
jusqu'à penser bien sûr vous allez me
dire le contraire jusqu'à penser qu' ils
ont d'autant plus signer cet accord
qu'ils savent qu'il n'y aura pas de
majorité de gauche à l'assemblée
nationale et que puisqu'on va de toute
façon vers l'échec autant préserver les
boutiques les financements les élus
autant que possible c'est un accord
législatif et le ce point de vue il faut
chapeau à mélangeant c'était pas évident
qu'ils se prêtent complètement à tout ça
ils avaient jusqu'à maintenant toujours
tourné le dos ce genre d'accord il n'a
toujours pas utilisé depuis cinq ans le
mot de gauche a un sens pour lui là
c'est fait mais ça nous dit rien sur ce
qui va se passer dans la vie politique
ensuite leur à des groupes
parlementaires chacun sera autonome
chacun va re découvrir qu'il n'est pas
sur beaucoup de points d'accord avec
l'autre ils ont fait un accord électoral
ça n'est pas un accord politique de
gouvernement christophe barbier vous
partager ce point de vue où il ya quand
même une part d'aggiornamento de mise à
jour du logiciel politique du ps
les deux c'est à dire je vois cette
mécanique à l'oeuvre et je m'inquiète de
la suite c'est à dire du prix
idéologique que pourraient payer le
parti socialiste dans cette affaire si
ça se termine par une gauche
multipartite d'opposition avec un groupe
ps qui a sauvé son existence et qui en
effet continuer à travailler au national
et pas seulement local chacun reprenant
ses idées son indépendance et finalement
faisant chambre à part bon ça aurait été
une manoeuvre électorale assez habile
puisque ça évite au ps de disparaître
parce que si elle est fille avait voulu
présenter des candidats concurrents au
ps dans toutes les circonscriptions
gagnables pour le ps ça pouvait faire
des dégâts mais je ne suis pas certain
que les concessions idéologique fait à
la ans insoumise ne pèse pas lourd et
longtemps dans la reconstruction d'une
gauche socialiste ou social-démocrate de
gouvernement je pense notamment après
l'europe corinne narassiguin travaux ps
reste un parti de gouvernement donc mais
moi je crois au contraire que nous en
avons nous allons négocier nous avons
beaucoup bataillé pour négocier cet
accord sur une base de coalition et dans
l'esprit de ce qu'on pouvait faire nous
même quand on était en position
d'organiser les rassemblements c'est à
dire qu'on a jamais demandé aux
socialistes écologistes et communistes
de devenir socialiste quand il quand on
monte un gouvernement on a fait la
gauche plurielle
c'est motivant donc c'est dans cet
esprit là que nous avons négocié l'idée
ça n'est pas évidemment de dire qu'on
doit aller au bout du bout arrivée sur
un programme où on est tous d'accord sur
tout non il va falloir le et le travail
continue puisqu'il ya un socle un socle
pour l'heure croire programmatique été
décidé mais il ya des ailes du travail
programmatique qui continue sur les
prochains jours pour élargir cette base
l'idée c'est que justement on puisse
continuer à détailler ce sur quoi on est
d'accord mais aussi clarifier les sujets
sur lesquels on continue à garder notre
grand père justement c'est notre
identité politique j'ai des questions
vous posez là dessus que pense le parti
socialiste sur plusieurs sujets
importants par exemple sur la retraite
vous êtes d'accord sur la retraite à 60
ans qui figure donc dans la corsa c'est
écrit noir sur blanc mais ses 60 ans
pour qui et avec combien d'annuités
parce qu'en fait on peut dire 60 ans
mais elle fait partie justement dit je
sais pas toi ça fait partie de ce qu'on
a encore donc continuer à travailler
nous nous sommes d'accord sur le nom
nous notre point de vue par rapport aux
retraités nous n'en avons pas changé
c'est la question de la justice et donc
de la question du temps de vie en bonne
santé de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé quand on est à la retraite et donc
de prendre en compte le fait que quand
on a des métiers pénibles quand on a eu
des carrières longues c'est normal qu'on
puisse avoir le droit de partir à la
retraite à 60 ans avec une retraite
décente et donc qu'on puisse aller vers
une
une réforme qui disent l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite c'est 60 ans pour
que ces personnes là puissent partir à
la retraite véritablement à 60 ans ça
nous pose aucun problème mais pas pour
tous par contre je pense qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on regarde encore les
questions de financement que ce soit
sérieux et qu' on considère que dans le
système ce soit tout à fait acceptable
que des cols blancs par exemple puissent
partir à 65 ans ou au delà ça n'est pas
la position aujourd'hui de la france
insoumise qui fait un peu d'un slogan de
communication politique aussi le fait de
résumer la réforme de la retraite à une
retraite à 60 ans on entend ça mais si
on veut aller au bout d'une réforme de
retraites qui tient la route pour nous
bah c'est sûr qu'on se met d'accord
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la
prise en compte de la pénibilité des
carrières longues et des carrières
hachées sur l'europe donc vous êtes
d'accord pour déroger de façon
transitoire aux règles communes si cela
empêche d'appliquer ce programme commun
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de dire à
viktor orban bon bah c'est ok vous
pouvez vous aussi déroger aux règles
communes à l'europe dès lors que vous
vous inscrivez dans un gouvernement dans
le cadre d'une démocratie libérale vous
avez fait campagne là dessus allez-y non
justement c'est alors si on a fait très
attention à préciser ça dans le texte on
a on a fait un texte assez complet pour
préciser les paramètres en fait c'est
alors on a fait ça avec opus avec les
notes délégation socialiste au départ et
au parlement européen avec sylvie
guillaume en particulier qui est une
européenne convaincue qu'ils n'auraient
rien laisser passer ce que nous avons
dit c'est qu'il ya des rapports de force
à construire sur les questions
spécifiquement sur les questions
économiques sociales budgétaire
environnementale là où on pense que
l'europe à incourt libérale qui ne va
pas dans ce sens une europe protectrice
et que là on peut utiliser l'outil de la
delà de la dérogation transitoire comme
un rapport de force pour changer les
règles et on l'a fait collectivement à
plusieurs pays emmanuel macron y compris
pendant la période qu'ovide parce qu'il
ya des moments où on voit que finalement
c'est possible de changer la séquence a
fait consensus mais
l'idée c'est de ces deux de créer des
rapports de force et d'embarquer
d'autres pays avec nous mais on a aussi
été très clair que sur l'état de droit
sur les droits fondamentaux sur la
question des libertés individuelles
là il n'y a pas de dérogation possible
est ce que c'est une rupture idéologique
importante à vos yeux christophe barbier
sur 7 sion de l'europe déroger de façon
même transitoire aux règles communes oui
bien sûr on en revient à un débat qui
anime et le ps en 2005 lors du
référendum sur la constitution
européenne on avait déjà vu cette
fracture on avait bien vu ce qu'ils
cherchaient un plan b qui ne l'ont pas
trouvé d'ailleurs malgré leur victoire
au référendum et ceux qui étaient pour
une continuité mitterrandienne si j'ose
dire et l'a finalement revient ce débat
là avec l'idée qu'il ya un plan b
possible qui est d'avancer toujours en
europe mais en imposant ou en proposant
d'autres règles à nos partenaires savent
habite buté sur un autre socialiste qui
s'appelle olaf scholz et qui est à
berlin et qui lui ne va sans doute pas
partager cette voie là si vous avez la
marge brute à la sueur et
les allemands aussi les espagnols les
portugais il ya tous des domaines où ils
dérogent à certaines règles et donc en
réalité cette pratique là elle existe
elle est la france a déjà dérogé avec
tous les gouvernements de toutes les
couleurs politiques alors on va
justement pouvoir va pouvoir vérifier ça
l'avait si vous voulez au questionnement
il ya désobéissance à nous ça sera
soumise en entente désobéissance monde
c'était vous en en interrogation c'est
pour ça qu'on a on a été très prudent
sur la manière dont à formuler les
choses c'est pour ça que si vous êtes
une opposition multipartite ce sera
facile de gérer ces différences dans le
temps si vous êtes une coalition de
gouvernement il faut tout de suite
passer aux travaux pratiques ce sera
beaucoup plus difficile on va voir ce
qu'on pense en tout cas les sociaux
démocrates allemands puisque nous sommes
en liaison vidéo vidéo avec rené rey
basique et donc eurodéputés et membre du
spd allemand bonsoir monsieur et et
merci rld est d'être avec nous alors
qu'elle regardait ce que vous portez
vous sur cet accord politique signé par
le parti socialiste avec la france
insoumise skis à certains points qui
vous inquiète
mais bon le soir merci de m'éviter de
parler ici effectivement honnêtement je
salue cet accord parce que mon avis le
plus grand problème pour l'europe c'est
l'extrême droite en france et le danger
qu'il y aura un président et d'extrême
droite dans cinq ans et à mon avis ce
qu'il faut à pour avoir une pour ne pas
avoir une extrême droite qui est au
pouvoir
dans cinq enfants c'est une gauche
chimie est ce qu'on voit maintenant
c'est la première étape de père vers une
gauche unie qui est une antenne active
crédible pour l'extrême droite parce
qu'en ce moment là on a la politique
conservatrice libérale de macron vers la
politique d'extrême droite et maintenant
on a la chance de présenter qu'il y en a
une vraie alternative gauche de messi
mais ça veut dire ce que ça ne nous
dérangerait pas que la france déroge à
certaines règles communes à tous les
états membres de l'union européenne que
ce soit sur la réduction des déficits
publics où que ce soit je ne sais pas
par exemple sur la libre concurrence sur
le marché de l'énergie dès lors qu'on
veut encadrer les prix de l'électricité
ou du gaz
oui certainement j'ai aussi lu cette
phrase et ça m'inquiète comme phrase
mais quand même comme c'était 17 une
phrase très bien rédiger parce qu'elle
dit il faut d'amour que les règles
européennes on pêche la réalisation de
certaines politiques de gauche et là je
peux vous dit
nous avons un problème dans la liaison
vidéo avec rené rey pas si je sais pas
si si on va réussir à la voile a rétabli
je suis de retour je crois oui on vous
voir vous entendez y voilà
donc comme comme comme j'ai dit j'ai lu
cette phrase est à mon avis ça te fasses
est bien rédigé par ce qu'elle dit on
des roches si les règles européennes on
pêche la réalisation d'une politique de
gauche
et comme je sais pas seulement depuis
titre du parlement européen mais aussi
professeur de droit européen je peux
dire il ya quand même pas mal des choses
qui lui colle que l'on peut faire à
l'intérieur de droit européen donc la
chance de cet accord c'est maintenant de
deux aussi faire preuve qu'une politique
progressiste est possible en même temps
d'être pro européen est-ce que moi dont
l'espagne avec les et sociaux-démocrates
au portugal mais aussi les
sociaux-démocrates en allemagne c'est
possible d'avoir les deux et à mon avis
assez local ça c'est la grande chance de
cet accord aussi un dernier mot toujours
sur l'international la france insoumise
elle souhaite que la france sorte de
l'otan elle refuse de livrer délà des
armes à l'ukraine certains lui
reprochent d'avoir été longtemps ambiguë
avec vladimir poutine sur ces trois
points est ce que vous estimez que le
parti socialiste a suffisamment
clarifier les choses avec son partenaire
de la france insoumise
c'est ma lecture de cet accord qu'il y a
il y a des idées et des fondamentale
quand
d'être peut-être faire partir de l'otan
et de soutenir l'ukraine a mon avis oui
c'est bien clair très bien merci
beaucoup on est repassés d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur sur lcp rhône et
terol ça vous surprend d'entendre social
démocrate allemand va soutenir cet
accord cette union ville et les sociaux
démocrates allemands sont très habiles
dans les négociations partisane
eux-mêmes ils auraient une coalition qui
a créé partie de leur culture politique
ils sont plus à droite que qu'emmanuel
macro chez nous donc mais c'est assez
astucieux parce que on fait dire au
texte de l'accord ce qu'on veut qu'il
qu'ils disent et ça n'est pas évident la
politique ça n'est quand même pas de lui
décorticage de phrases pour leur faire
dire ce qu'on souhaite y lire imaginez
qui est une majorité de ce genre et
qu'on ait une cohabitation
mélenchon dans une interview télévisée à
qui on avait dit mais en matière
d'europe de politique étrangère de
défense et le président quel époux voir
comment ça va se passer il a dit je dois
reconnaître que là dessus la
cohabitation ça sera chaud et je crois
que ça c'est vrai il ya réellement
malgré les phrases astucieusement
écrites il ya plus de désobéissance il
ya des dérogations ponctuelles histoire
quelque chose comme ça transitoire bah
c'est un vrai problème qui se posera cas
par cas devant chaque dossier européen
et on voit bien que macron et cette
éventuelle gauche unie n'auront pas les
mêmes positions c'est ingérable vous
êtes projeté dans oui c'est idéal pour
une culture d'opposition parce que
chacun dit ce qu'il veut dans l'accord
et on canarde tous le même gouvernement
c'est très compliqué comme contrat de
gouvernement fait donc en fait c'est
mieux pour vous de perdre législatif
mais c'est pour ça que c'est fait je
crois que sur les préoccupations qui
sont les préoccupations principales des
français aujourd'hui ce sur quoi il veut
être sur les questions économiques
sociales environnementales à gauche je
crois que là tu aurais de grosses
convergence effectivement je ne nie pas
sûr que sur le fait sur les questions
européennes et internationales
il y aura des divergences et que parfois
notamment sur la question de temps
évidemment ça sera plus facile de se
mettre d'accord avec le président mâcon
qu'avec un premier ministre jean luc
mélenchon mais je vais vous dire bedri
n'ose y penser qu'on devait sortir de
l'otan et on n'a jamais exclu du parti
socialiste pour ça voilà donc on sait
aussi pouvoir c'est aussi on a la
culture du débat parlementaire c'est
aussi ça le rôle de 2 à notre conception
de la démocratie et c'est normal que
parfois il puisse y avoir des majorités
qui se forment différemment il ya un
dernier point qui m'inquiète moi c'est
la laïcité parce qu'olivier fort et anne
hidalgo pendant la présidentielle avait
été très clair sur la conception
républicaine de la laïcité vous même
vous avez lutté à l'intérieur du ps vous
avez cheminée pour aboutir à une des
positions très fermes et là on a
l'impression que ben voilà c'est la
ligne 2 et les filles dont certains vont
jusqu'à l'islamo gauchisme c'est à dire
un nouveau prolétariat musulmans qui l'a
emporté nous avons aussi insisté pour
que dans le texte paraissent bien la
question de la défense de la république
universaliste laïque et la question de
la lutte contre toutes les
discriminations et contre tous les
replis communautaristes donc ça c'est
noir sur blanc dans le texte et j'ai
même fait dire aux négociateurs de la
france soumise même si nous n'avons pas
réussi à aller jusqu'à le mettre noir
sur blanc dans le texte que il n'y avait
pas à toucher aux lois de laïcité
existantes dans le pays est contraint la
dernière loi votée sous le quinquennat
vaincrons parce que c'est
donc qu'ils étaient faux et qu'ils
étaient très très clairs sur la loi de
1905 à la 2015 est difficile sur les
autres c'est pour ça que ça n'est pas
noir et blanc sur sur le texte mais ils
ont ils ont quand même été d'accord pour
que donc on a obtenu sa pour que ce soit
écrit noir sur blanc le respect de la
république laïque universaliste et donc
après c'est à eux de démontrer si ils
sont capables d'être en cohérence dans
leurs actes dans l'eure dans les
positions qu'ils prennent avec cet
engagement là voilà alors il ya une
question qui se pose maintenant c'est de
savoir ce que vont faire les opposants à
cet accord au sein du parti socialiste
on l'a évoqué avec stéphane blakowski ce
sont donc les tenants d'une ligne
sociale-démocrate globalement qui se
sont opposés à ce texte marque au
pommier est allé interviewer l'un d'eux
françois kalfon
bonjour france gens font il ya quelques
heures le parti socialiste a donc adopté
le projet d'accord avec la france
insoumise vous vous étiez contre dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous aujourd'hui
écoutez j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire
des camarades déjà j'observe que on a pu
le dire 1 parce que au parti socialiste
c'est une démocratie interne ce qui
n'existe pas la france a soumises mon
état d'esprit il est que j'ai envie de
dire tout ça pour ça
finalement lâché notre culture de
gouvernement lâche et notre crédibilité
auprès des français pour une poignée de
circonscriptions putative je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage on a le sentiment
que beaucoup d'électeurs à gauche
réclamait quand même cette union est
pourquoi vous avez refusé cette alliance
alors la france un sony ce vendredi
parce que c'est vrai que c'était un peu
difficile à comprendre
lyon de la gauche oui mille fois oui
mais l'union autour d'un homme clivant
et d'un programme qui n'est pas un
programme de gauche mais un problème de
gauche radicale je crains qu'il ya un
problème d'efficacité électorale mais
surtout les domaines vous avez une
impasse budgétaire très forte du
programme de jean luc mélenchon plus de
300 milliards de dépenses nouvelles et
on ne sait pas comment tout cela
et je veux dire que ça finalement
affaibli
des revendications qui elles peuvent
être partagés sur le blocage d'un
certain nombre de prix ou encore sûr
finalement le refus la retraite à 65 ans
c'est quoi la suite pour les socialistes
comme vous est ce que vous allez entrer
en résistance vous allez quitter le
parti socialiste n'ont écouté j'ai envie
de dire que c'est plutôt le parti
socialiste est en train de me quitter
parce que il a décidé d'être finalement
un subalterne
de jean-luc mélenchon et la france
assouline maintenant on va rester très
calme c'est à la fin de la foire qu'on
compte les bouses et la fin de la foire
c'est le 19 juin prochain je constate
que à date le bilan est déjà extrêmement
mauvais eu égard au nombre de départs du
parti socialiste parce que vous le savez
très bien dans les territoires on ne
rassemble pas des socialistes des
communistes parfois même des insoumis ou
des verts et beaucoup de citoyens des
associations par un programme qui est
dans la surenchère de la radicalité on
les rassemble par le dialogue par une
certaine forme de modération qui à mille
lieux de la culture de la france
insoumise merci françois kalfon merci à
vous alors corinne narassiguin qu'est ce
que vous répondez un françois kalfon qui
s'interroge beaucoup sur le financement
de toutes les mesures auxquelles vous
avez souscrit
et puis sur sa place au sein de ce parti
même s'il n'envisage pas de le quitter
il semble ne plus partager toutes les
idées toutes les valeurs que vous portez
vous est ce qu'il a encore sa place au
sein du ps mais bien sûr il ya toujours
eu des d une grande variété d'opinions
et de courants au sein du parti
socialiste a toujours été un parti
vivant et c'est normal et c'est aussi
comme ça dans ces débats là qu'on
progresse et on peut s'interroger et
c'est bien mais je crois que il ya eu un
vote très claire du parti du parti
socialiste il ya aussi
une attente très forte et c'est à ça
qu'on répond aujourd'hui à une attente
très forte des électrices et des
électeurs qui ont dit ce qu'il pensait
justement des différences entre eux
enfin de l'importance de la gauche de
gouvernement et de ce que françois
kalfon appelle une gauche radicale qui
serait irréaliste et c'est ben nous on a
fait 1,7 pour cent à l'élection
présidentielle et mélangeant le
mélenchon il a fait 22 % dans ses 22 %
il ya bien sûr beaucoup de vote utile
donc il ya beaucoup de nos électeurs des
électeurs socialistes électeurs
écologistes des électeurs communistes
mais qui ont considéré que c'était plus
important d'essayer de mettre la gauche
au deuxième tour plutôt que de sadate
s'attarder sur cette terre faten
différence et donc ça il faut l'entendre
et aujourd'hui il ya 90 % des
sympathisants de gauche qui veulent un
rassemblement et donc nous ce que nous
avons l'ambition d'apporter dans ce
rassemblement
c'est justement le fait que nous
continuons à être un parti de
gouvernement mais ce que aussi cela
clarification nous apportons en
choisissant de rejoindre cette union
c'est de dire on se souvient de nos
racines le parti socialiste a d'abord
été un parti qui a porté des réformes
radicales qui a porté des
transformations du pays avec une
radicalité parce que les congés payés
la semaine de 40 heures puisque plus de
35 heures la salle à la cmu l'abolition
de la peine de mort mariage pour tous
tout ça ce sont des réformes radicales
et donc ce qu'on a ce qu'on est devenu
aux yeux des électeurs de gauche c'est
juste un parti de gestionnaires qui gère
le réel et qui corrigent à la marge et
ben ça n'intéresse plus les français
roland cayrol il faut aujourd'hui une
part de radicalité dans le discours
politique pour se faire entendre des
français notamment des classes moyennes
ou des classes populaires c'est écoutez
moi je trouve à la fois que ce qu'a dit
qu'elles font sur le financement du
programme mélenchon est vrai je me suis
tapé les trois heures de vidéos qui sont
faites pour essayer d'expliquer est
réellement on n'arrive pas à compter ce
qu'ils prétendent être un équilibre des
dépenses et des recettes c'est un
programme réalisable je pense aussi que
caroline narassiguin a raison sur le
fait qu' à blain de leurs électeurs qui
ont voté utile parce qu'il voulait la
gauche au second tour et qui sont
attachés à l'idée d'unité mais ses
électeurs si on regarde dans nos
sondages ceux qui se réclament du parti
socialiste qui n'ont pas voté - hidalgo
c'est un électorat qui reste modérée sur
le plan politique qui demande des
réformes qui apprécient la culture
gouvernementale et qui n'est pas radical
et il ya là une opposition avec des
militants qui eux jeunes il ya un
problème générationnel très clair au
parti socialiste qui a besoin de
recruter des jeunes et leurs jeunes ils
sont derrière l'accord parce que il
pense qu'il faut être radical qui en a
marre de ce parti purement gestionnaire
et ça c'est une équation extrêmement
compliqué à résoudre et qu'il faut
résoudre est à mon avis le mot social
démocrate ne sert à rien parce que la
social démocratie c'est quasiment fini
en europe même au spd on dit sont au
pouvoir non ils sont ils ont fait le
plus mauvais score électoral de leur
histoire donc à part le cas portugais
parce que en scandinavie c'est pire ils
sont devenus souvent xénophobes et les
socialistes donc la social démocratie
elle à appliquer son programme en europe
nous vivons sur les acquis de la social
démocratie il leur faut donc et à vous
et à vos opposants internes trouver des
formes nouvelles d'existence d'un parti
socialiste qui soit sans doute un peu
plus radicale mais aussi un peu plus
adapté problème de ce temps sans quoi
attention la disparition ça sera pas
seulement l'effacement idéologique dans
lequel vous vous êtes inscrits
aujourd'hui mais une disparition
politique alors vous évoquez d'un mot là
le risque de décalage entre le souhait
des militants socialistes et celui des
électeurs socialistes où on s'est rendu
dans le 20e arrondissement paris dans
cette circonscription qui fait beaucoup
débat d'ailleurs un dans le cadre de
l'accord signé avec la france un
soumises circonscriptions où nous avons
rencontré deux électeurs socialistes
je vous propose d'écouter leur réaction
à cet accord
du dépit du désespoir de du dégoût
pourquoi ça parce que le la gauche a été
effectivement un espoir j'ai appartenu à
la gauche elle appartenait au parti
socialiste et les résultats ont été
catastrophiques mais là c'est le sait la
fin quoi c'est la décomposition totale
l'alliance de la carpe et du lapin donc
moi j'ai été élevé rendant la gauche
socialiste et je pense que
bon ça n'a pas vraiment à voir avec la
politique de la france insoumise en fait
je vais très souvent dans les
manifestations à la france insoumise
pourvoir pour sentir justement de change
des différences qu'il y a il ya de
grandes grandes différences alors
corinne narassiguin ça n'a pas valeur de
sondage on a tendu le micro dans la rue
et on est tombé sur des électeurs
socialistes mais quand même vous pensez
que ça va être facile pour qu'il y avait
encore mais dans la rue comme celles ci
sont uniquement des homosexuels facile
pour des électeurs socialistes de
prendre un bulletin et les fit et de le
mettre dans l'urne ça va se faire
facilement ça va être un bulletin de la
nouvelle union populaire et que
d'exister sociale et donc c'est ça qu'il
faut voir c'est que là on va on va être
sous une même bannière avec tous les
logos
de tous les partis qui participent à
cette réunion on rappelle que votre
agent que dans soixante dix
circonscriptions sur
570 et il y aura le soutien de
effectivement ça n'est pas la façon dont
nous nous négocions des désaccords
auparavant nous admettions une une
concurrence de deux candidatures à
gauche au premier tour quand il n'y
avait ni risque d'extrême droite ni
risque de basculement de la droite delà
de la circonscription mais ça n'a pas
été le choix de ce qui a été fait pour
pour cette pause et le cadre de cet
accord
et donc nous l'avons nous l'avons
accepté même si effectivement sur la
circonscription dans le 20e à paris nous
avons continué à avoir un point de
contentieux avec la france insoumise
puisqu'ils n'ont pas respecté une
circonscription sortante mais je je
crois que c'est normal que c'est un
cheminement je pense que c'est normal
qu'ils aient des interrogations chez des
électeurs sociale et justement par
rapport à aux fêtes que nous sommes
beaucoup opposé avec eux la france est
soumise au sein de la gauche
et mais je crois qu'il faut entendre
beaucoup plus puissamment la demande de
rassemblement et le fait que et chez les
saints soumis parce qu'eux aussi doivent
faire beaucoup d'efforts pour travailler
avec nous
et chez les insoumis et chez les
socialistes nous avons à prendre à
prendre ses efforts sur nous et aller
faire parce que ya cette attente des de
l'électorat de gauche le mot de la fin
christophe barbier scraire à risque de
démobilisation des électeurs socialistes
à la suite de cet accord oui il ya un
risque de désorientation parce qu'il ya
maintenant l'union qui vont être
contents et qu'ils vont revenir et cela
d'évidence ont voté à la présidentielle
il y en a d'autres qui étaient venus
pour un vote utile à la présidentielle
et qui vont trouver que c'est en effet
une alliance étrange et puis il va y
avoir aussi l'impact des tentations
schismatique serre si demain il ya une
sorte de nouveau ps qui se crée avec les
dissidents qui refusent cet accord ça va
aussi attirer des électeurs sans compter
évidemment la macro ni qui tend déjà la
main ou aux sociaux-démocrates au socio
libéraux qui pourrait la rejoindre et à
tirer avec eux aussi des électeurs je
pense notamment des électeurs cadres
actifs de centre-ville donc tout ça ça
va être quand même les turbulences d'ici
législatives qui vont servir en quelque
sorte de crash test à cette tendance
elle sera peut-être le début de quelque
chose si les groupes parlementaires sont
sauvées si on continue à travailler sur
le programme si on est dans l'opposition
parce que je continue à penser que
l'expérience du pouvoir serait trop
précoce et trop périlleuse et puis il ya
une dernière question qui va se poser
pour que ça marche cette nouvelle union
de la gauche c'est le retrait de
mélenchon cirque on voit bien que cette
personnalité qui est un formidable atout
de tryba est aussi un formidable
handicap il faut être dans la radicalité
pour y arriver au second tour mais dans
la réalité radicalité c'est la certitude
de perdre le second tour et c'est
radicalité alain visage c'est celui de
jean luc mélenchon l'homme de la
république c'est moi l'homme des
policiers barbare c'est toujours trop
avec lui est ce que la france insoumise
va proposer autre chose est ce que cette
nouvelle gauche peut accoucher d'un
leader ou d'une leader dans cinq ans qui
soit à la fois assez puissant pour
attirer les jeunes la radicalité
positive le veut la vraie rupture mais
aussi assez consensuel pour être
crédible dans un second tour
présidentiel avec un programme financé
c'est un redoutable défi humain et
idéologique on va suivre évidemment ce
feuilleton des législatives dans l'est
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent c'est la fin de ce débat merci
beaucoup à tous les trois de la venue
sur le plateau d' lcp on va se pencher à
présent sur une autre question brûlante
c'est le cas de le dire celle du
réchauffement climatique avec un
spécialiste du sujet françois gemenne
qu'un membre du giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat on a plein de bonnes raisons de
l'invité comme nous l'expliquent en
détail nicolas coadou
si on vous invite aujourd'hui françois
gemenne c'est parce que tout comme vous
l'avenir de la planète et donc celui de
l'humanité nous inquiète quelque peu ses
morts
pour moi c'est mort depuis la sortie du
troisième rapport du giec le 4 avril
dernier des propos réalistes pour les
uns fataliste pour les autres en tout
cas qui font réfléchir jusqu'à twitter
charmant réseau social ou des
internautes vous invite à lire
l'introduction d'un rapport que vous
avez vous même écrit mais trêve de
plaisanterie françois gemenne voici
votre cv non exhaustif vous êtes entre
autre politologue chercheur spécialiste
dans les migrations climatiques vous
dirigez l'observatoire hugo enseigné à
l'université de liège et à sciences po
paris et vous êtes n'en déplaise à vos
détracteurs l'un des auteurs principaux
du giec d'ailleurs selon venu et
sincèrement je ne pense pas que la
démocratie soit capable aujourd'hui de
mettre en oeuvre les changements
nécessaires à la transformation alors ce
serait beau si vous y croyez encore je
vous félicite et je me suis d'arrivée
moi je n'y crois plus alors on imagine
qu'il ya peu de chance de vous voir vous
installer au ministère de l'écologie
dans le prochain gouvernement
je veux pas donner l'illusion que ma
présence au gouvernement
signifie qu'on est à la hauteur sur ces
enjeux là il y aurait pourtant de quoi
faire vous nous l'accorderez
heureusement le sujet est pris à bras le
corps par les jeunes générations
[Musique]
ce sont d'ailleurs les 18 34 ans qu'ils
voteraient le plus pur des programmes
jugés compatibles avec les engagements
écologiques pour eux tout n'est pas
perdu illustration sans doute et sans
vous faire offense de l'optimisme de la
jeunesse alors françois gemenne on vous
pose la question si la démocratie et les
politiques sont impuissants pour sauver
la planète acquis en incombe la tâche la
parole est à vous
bonsoir alors et c'est évidemment envie
de vous la posez cette question bien sûr
de sauver la planète si ça ne passe pas
par la politique ça ne passe pas en tout
cas par la démocratie représentative je
crois qu'on peut pas réduire la
politique aux élections ni la démocratie
aux élections et ça ça me paraît très
important et je te dire que il me semble
que pendant longtemps en tout cas moi
personnellement jusque 2018 2019 j'ai
imaginé qu'ils allaient avoir un grand
basculement d'une majorité conscientiser
et que la question du climat allait
devenir véritablement l'enjeu numéro un
la priorité numéro un mais force est de
constater que même si beaucoup de gens
reconnaissent que c'est une priorité un
enjeu important sa semelle à d'autres
enjeux tout aussi important sur des
enjeux de sécurité des enjeux
d'inégalités et c'est ces gens juste
sont évidemment connectés entre eux mais
toute une série de gens ne sont pas
prêts aujourd'hui je crois aux
transformations qui serait nécessaire
pour atteindre les objectifs de l'accord
de paris est donc serein parce qu'elles
sont trop douloureuse parce que sont
trop douloureuse pour vous donner un
simple exemple le giec nous dit que pour
atteindre ces objectifs il faut réduire
de 40 3% nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 à l'heure actuelle elle
continue d'augmenter d'environ 1% 1% et
demi par an donc ça veut dire que c'est
absolument gigantesque que l'effort
qu'il faut faire et beaucoup de gens je
pense n'ont pas réalisé ou ne réalisent
pas l'ampleur de cet effort est donc ça
veut dire que si cet effort doit être
fait je crois que ça va plutôt venir de
minorité très déterminé d'entreprises de
collectivités ou de la société civile
qui font aussi de la politique à leur
manière et c'est aussi la démocratie
mais je crois que c'est important de
réaliser que il ne faut pas trop
attendre des gouvernements parce que le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit même des
gouvernements très engagé sur l'écologie
ne vont avoir que quelque part une
petite marge d'ajustement
quand on voit l'effet d'une mesurette
comme réduire de 10 kilomètres à l'heure
la vitesse maximum sur les autoroutes
quand on voit le tollé que ça provoque
on se rend compte que même si un
gouvernement voulait faire de cette
mesure le fer de lance de sa politique
écologie qui mettrait sans doute trois
ou quatre ans pour la mettre en oeuvre
il devrait faire face à des
manifestations des aménagements etc et
ce ne serait qu'une toute petite partie
de l'effort mais mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'écologie n'est pas
acceptable socialement aujourd'hui est
ce que c'est ça le fond du problème il
faut la rendre acceptable socialement je
pense que d'abord il faut la rendre non
seulement acceptable socialement mais
aussi désirable socialement et le
problème je crois c'est que beaucoup
voient l'écologie comme une cause mais
pas comme quelque chose qui touche
directement à leurs intérêts et les gens
naturellement vont avoir tendance à
voter pour leurs propres intérêts vont
voter pour des gens qui pensent qu'ils
vont pouvoir améliorer leur vie au cours
du prochain mandat et le problème c'est
que si vous votez pour le climat vous
votez non seulement pour améliorer votre
vie mais surtout pour améliorer la vie
des autres de gens qui ne font pas
partie du corps électoral parce qu'ils
ne sont pas encore nés ou parce qu'ils
habitent à l'autre bout du monde et donc
c'est pour ça je crois que l'écologie
aujourd'hui en tout cas en politique
électorale touche une certaine limite
parce qu' elle ne parvient pas à toucher
des électeurs qui vont voter avant tout
pour leur intérêt plutôt que pour une
cause
j'aimerais qu'on revenus convient quand
même sur ces mots vous avez prononcé qui
ont eu beaucoup d'écho quand vous avez
dit ces morts où il va pas y arriver
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire par là
c'est à dire que ça y est c'est trop
tard c'est à non non c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard depuis 1950 c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est plus du tout en
capacité d'éviter la sortie de route en
matière climatique aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on peut faire c'est limité la casse
limiter le nombre de tonneaux que la
voiture va faire et donc effectivement
c'est pas un peu pessimiste comme ça
mais je crois qu'il faut sortir de
l'idée que le changement climatique sur
un problème binaire on est sur un
problème graduelle et donc chaque demi
degré et va faire la différence chaque
tonne de co2 va faire la différence par
contre là où je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître certaines limites d'où
l'expression c'est mort c'est quand à la
capacité est un gouvernement que notre
démocratie parviennent encore à arriver
aux objectifs de l'accord de paris quand
on regarde les tendances quand on
regarde l'objectif il faut pouvoir être
raisonnable aussi et dire la vérité aux
gens c'est à dire que nous n'arriverons
sans doute pas à atteindre les objectifs
de l'accord de paris et que donc il faut
se préparer pour des impacts du
changement climatique beaucoup plus
important beaucoup plus lourd que ce
qu'on avait prévu pourra pas limitée aux
1° 5 de l'accord de paris les seins je
pense qu'il faut de toute façon on
oublié ça veut dire qu'il faut s'adapter
c'est ça l'idée absolue réchauffement
mais cela veut dire quoi concrètement
s'adapter est-ce que c'est pas aussi se
résigner quelque part quand on s'adapte
c'est qu'on accepte à situer bien sûr
quelque part l'adaptation une forme
d'aveu d'échec que nos efforts de
réduction des émissions n'ont pas été
suffisants que pour éviter et les
impacts du changement climatique mais ça
c'est une réalité donc il faut pouvoir
regarder les choses en face et se le
dire mais ça veut dire quoi s'adapter
pas non j'aimerais qu'on prenne
l'exemple de ce qu a vécue l'inde ces
derniers jours une canicule vraiment
dingue les températures ont frôlé les 50
degrés par endroits avec un taux
d'humidité très élevé qui fait que
certaines parties de l'inde ne sont plus
habitables par l'homme sont aujourd'hui
s'adapter pour les indiens ça veut dire
quoi alors c'est là qu'on touche
précisément aux limites de l'adaptation
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui c'est
l'habitabilité de la planète qui est
mise en cause si les températures à
peine 50 degrés pendant des périodes
prolongées ce sont les fonctions vitales
du corps humain qui ne sont plus assurés
il y à certaines zones qui pourraient
être inondées en permanence ou devenir
incultivables donc au touche aux limites
de l'adaptation d'où l'importance de
faire tout ce qu'on peut pour réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
en france l'adaptation qu'est ce que ça
va vouloir dire ça vouloir dire par
exemple des travaux d'infrastructures
pour nous protéger contre la hausse du
niveau de la mer ça veut dire dans les
villes mettre davantage de végétation de
manière à pouvoir faire baisser la
température et éviter les phénomènes
d'îlots de chaleur urbains ça veut dire
aussi mieux prévenir les populations et
avoir des plans d'évacuation des
populations en cas de catastrophe
naturelle et là on est encore très très
en retard parce qu'on imagine toujours
que les impacts du changement climatique
vont arriver à d'autres avant nous tous
chez nous alors j'aimerais qu'on voit
une carte que météo france a publié
cette semaine et qui permet justement de
prendre conscience que ce réchauffement
climatique il est déjà à l'oeuvre en
france elle compare les températures
moyennes et les précipitations moyenne
des 30 dernières années par rapport aux
trente années précédentes et en fait on
se rend que le climat de strasbourg
aujourd'hui correspond climat de lyon il
ya 30 ans et celui de paris aujourd'hui
au climat de bordeaux il y a trente ans
ça c'est du concret ça devrait parler
aux gens bien sûr et nous ne sommes
encore en france qu'à 1,1 degré
d'élévation de la température si tout va
bien dans le scénario le plus optimiste
on sera deux degrés et d'élévation de la
température ça veut dire que le climat
de paris dans 20 ou 30 ans ça sera
plutôt celui de toulouse ou de marseille
oui mais comment vous expliquez que bah
ça ne provoque pas de réaction parce que
là on est dans le concret où on est en
train d'entrer aujourd'hui dans une
phase de sécheresse en france au début
du mois de mai je vais avoir les
températures records la semaine
prochaine dans quelque part nous sommes
dans un état de la praxis et à dire que
l'on sait mais que l'on se trouve
incapable d'agir en tout cas d'agir
collectivement notamment parce que c'est
un phénomène graduelle et que donc on ne
voit pas de changement immédiat et
brusque mais qu'on voit le changement
peu à peu graduellement et aussi parce
que je crois qu'on a tendance à se
réfugier parfois derrière des mécanismes
de dénis qui vont nous faire imaginer
qu'en fait ce sont les autres qui vont
être touchés notamment parce que les
images qui sont convoqués pour parler du
changement climatique ce sont seulement
des images exotiques d'ours polaires sur
des icebergs ou de populations indigènes
à l'autre bout du monde elle nous reste
assez peu de temps j'aimerais qu'on
écoute jean jouzel que vous connaissez
bien climatologues qui a été vice
président du giec et qu'ils étaient
reçus de fait partie des climatologues
reçu en début de semaine par emmanuel
macron qui consultaient justement les
scientifiques pour préparer sa
planification de l'écologie et ne
partage pas votre point de vue je pense
qu'il vaut mieux que la communauté
scientifique au sens large souhaite
associer aux décisions soit bien sûr
soient associés à la marche des affaires
et c'est le rôle du haut conseil pour le
climat je crois que c'est quelque chose
quand même de bénéfique c'est aussi sur
crois que c'est le rôle d'une communauté
scientifique comme la nôtre que de tempa
disons que lorsque nous sommes
sollicités par les décideurs politiques
nous puissions y répondre c'est quand
même ça notre démarche vous comprenez un
peu ce qui est ce qui dit vous êtes
d'accord avec lui parce que qui d'autre
que les scientifiques pour alerter la
classe de médiation c'est pourquoi je
crois pas à la science pour la séance je
crois que le rôle de la danse est aussi
d'informer en politiques publiques vous
avez quand même un rôle à tenir
vis-à-vis des dirigeants à je pense
maintenant la question c'est jusqu'à
quel point est-ce qu'on se rend complice
de l'inaction et j'ai tendance à dire
que parfois on a trop attendu des
gouvernements moi je suis parfois
frappées du débat public qui dit sans
cesse les gouvernements doivent en faire
davantage doivent agir plus mais le
problème c'est que ces gouvernements peu
partout en europe ils ne reçoivent pas
de mandat clair de leurs électeurs pour
en faire davantage et que donc si on
veut en faire davantage il va falloir je
crois passer par d'autres biais alors
ces autres bien vous les avez évoqué
d'un mot c'est autre levier vous parlez
d'une minorité très déterminé dans les
entreprises dans la société civile ça
veut dire quoi il faut mener des coups
de force comme ça des micros actions
peuvent forcément des coups de force
mais il faut soutenir ceux au sein des
entreprises qui vont pouvoir faire
bouger et faire évoluer la culture de
certaines entreprises je prends par
exemple l'exemple des institutions
bancaires qui aujourd'hui financent
encore très largement des projets
d'énergies fossiles il faut pouvoir
travailler avec ceux qui à l'intérieur
de ces banques veulent réorienter les
investissements vers des investissements
plus durable ça ça me paraît essentiel
il faut travailler avec les
collectivités qui met en place
aujourd'hui des politiques expérimental
et qui montrent que ces politiques
peuvent s'appliquer plus largement à
l'échelle d'un territoire merci beaucoup
françois djemel je rappelle votre
dernier livre on a tous un ami noir la
maison d'édition jaillard chez fayard
voilà vous restez avec nous pour la
dernière partie de l'émission puisque on
accueille à présent nos a franchi avec
elsa monde un gars qui va nous détailler
les premières investitures aux
législatives au sein de la majorité
présidentielle
brandon ouaret va nous parler des
signaux politiques que les présidents
élus ont voulu envoyer en nommant leur
premier premier ministre en début de
mandat et puis enfin avec delphine
sabattier on s'intéressera à ce projet
d'appeler du gouvernement pour valider
notre identité en ligne sans
reconnaissance faciale c'est bien ça
exactement on commence par vous elsa
bonjour bonsoir à tous les jours dans ça
vous regarde votre chronique les 577
puisqu'ils sont 577 à être élus aux
législatives
à l'assemblée nationale les 12 et 19
juin aujourd'hui vous avez épluché vous
avez cannes est en quelque sorte la
première vague d'investiture au sein de
la majorité qu'est ce qu'il faut en
retenir alors elles sont tombées hier
soir un peu après 20 heures ces
investitures je vous rappelle cette
majorité elle s'appelle ensemble qu'on
comprenne bien qu'ils sont tous ensemble
qu'ils partent groupe et la république
en marche nouveau nom renaissance modem
et horizon alors 187 candidats moitié
d'hommes moitié de femmes s'en sont des
députés sortons 86 deux nouveaux
candidats et parmi eux il ya des
ministres et bien qu'ils ont décidé de
prendre les gants d'aller à la bataille
dans les législatives alors c'est le cas
d'elisabeth bornes par exemple dans le
calvados jean michel blanquer air dans
le loiret emmanuelle wargon dans le val
de marne brigitte klinkert sera dans le
haut rhin clément bonne à paris qui a
d'autres ministres qui sont investis
mais dans cette liste voilà ceux qui
vont au combat les législatives est ce
que dd sud dans un championnat qui
voulait être investis qui ne l'ont pas
été oui effectivement clément l'avait
dit pourtant normalement la règle
c'était que les sortants et avait la
priorité en général et bien tout est
dans la nuance du en général quelques
députés ont eu la désagréable surprise
de voir qu'il n'était pas investi qu'ils
avaient été sacrifiés alors ils sont six
ou sept dans ce cas là certains payent
le fait d'avoir voté contre un texte
d'avoir ce qui t'est la république en
marche même s'ils sont restés dans la
majorité d'avoir soutenu des listes
concurrentes certains ont eu des démêlés
avec la justice et puis pour certains il
a fallu tout simplement laisser un autre
candidat soutenu en haut lieu parce
qu'il faut s'attendre à des candidatures
dissidentes oui il y en a déjà stéphane
vosges état a d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'il maintenait sa candidature dans la
5e circonscription des français de
l'étranger il fera face donc à l'ancien
premier ministre manuel valls jean
charles larsonneur lui se dit prêt à
affronter dans sa circonscription de
bresse un candidat investi marc coatanéa
c'est un proche de richard ferrand
valérie petit dans le nord elle elle
tiendra une conférence de presse jeudi
prochain pour revenir sur son éviction
il donnera sa décision pour la députée
bien les persuader de faire les frais de
son inimitié et le mot est faible avec
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et puis je vois vous avez une
idée de sortie pour ceux qui voudraient
croiser des députés ou des futurs
députés ce week end alors traîné vers
aubervilliers dans les jours vous êtes
sûr normalement d'en croiser un ou deux
demain convention nationale de la nuque
mais ce nul nul on sait pas trop comment
l'appel pour l'instant la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale mardi
journée de formation pour les candidats
investis pour la majorité présidentielle
merci beaucoup l amende un gars va on
passe à vos bandes noires est bon soin
alors emmanuel macron pas été
officiellement investi demain à l'elysée
on attend toujours la nomination de son
premier ministre même s'il a donné quand
même quelques indices assez clair assez
précis un portrait-robot plutôt une
femme plutôt technocrates plutôt écolo
est orienté à gauche c'est ça qu'on en a
retenu en tout cas avec le profil du
premier premier ministre les présidents
cherchent à envoyer des messages
politiques en général oui dès le général
de gaulle à l'aube d'une nouvelle
république la cinquième il envoie un
message très fort son premier ministre
sera l'un de ses fidèles compagnons le
père de la nouvelle constitution michel
debré l'un des fondateurs du parti
gaulliste alors lorsque le premier
premier ministre se présente à la presse
pour la première fois on imagine toute
la pression qui pèse sur ses épaules
écoutez le en tout temps les
responsabilités gouvernementales sont
graves et comporte pour ceux qui les
acceptent d'impérieuses obligation
d'être choisis présentement
par le général de gaulle
pour présider le premier gouvernement de
la république nouvelle
comporte de plus graves responsabilités
encore et de plus sévère obligations
déjà on sentait que ça n'allait pas
durer trois ans plus tard michel debré
démissionne ou il a quand même résisté
trois ans pour le remplacer de gaulle
choisit un inconnu sont carrière
politique ce sera georges pompidou une
manière surtout de tourner
définitivement la page de la crise
algérienne et on le voit sur ces images
les la passation de pouvoir s'est faite
aussi très rapidement rien à voir avec
les longues cérémonie d'aujourd'hui une
simple poignée de main en 1974 valéry
giscard d'estaing lui avait une priorité
s'était affiché une forme de jeunesse et
de modernité bien bas le kennedy
français appelés à matignon le poulain
du défunt président pompidou ce sera
jacques chirac il le récompense surtout
pour le rôle qu'il a joué très important
mon du second tour il a ramené les voies
gaulliste un gaulliste pierre messmer
qui laisse sa place un autre gaulliste
jacques chirac alors forcément la
passation de pouvoir se passe à
merveille écoutez les
eh bien je viens de passer mes pouvoirs
au nouveau premier ministre
jacques chirac a toutes les qualités
nécessaires pour réussir dans ce poste
très lourd un moment difficile et c'est
pourquoi j'ai tout à fait confiance dans
son succès je vous remercie monsieur le
premier ministre je m'inspirais de votre
exemple il est positif s'il en est et je
tâcherai d'essayer de continuer dans
votre voix alors un autre message
politique important ça a été en 1991
quand françois mitterrand a nommé pour
la première fois une femme premier
ministre et à l'ambition première du
président mitterrand n'était pas de
nommer une femme à matignon mais surtout
de se débarrasser de michel rocard et
pour incarner le nouvel élan de sa
politique ait choisi edith cresson un
signal fort une première dans l'histoire
mais très vite la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement a dû faire face à de
violentes critiques sexistes notamment
dans la presse
et regardez c'est une publié au
lendemain de son entrée à matignon
libération qui titre et dieu nous sommes
à la femme emma avec un bouquet de
fleurs forcément françois re edit
l'atout charme de mitterrand le parisien
une femme à la barre qui rappelle
forcément le slogan de valéry giscard
d'estaing pour la présidence et 2,74
l'humanité on voit mitterrand qui qui
repose dans un escarpin avec les yeux
fermés avec cet escarpin sous forme de
toboggans et enfin le quotidien de paris
un titre très expressif matignon
figurez-vous au clément qu'il n'y a pas
que dans la presse qu edith cresson
était virulent à attaquer dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée aussi comme avec
le député de l'époque françois d'aubert
écoutez le vraiment on est dans un
système incroyablement monarchie
regardez le parcours de madame de
pompadour regardez le parcours des
discrétions il ya un parallélisme
certains alors pour jacques chirac en
1995 quel était le message politique
alors dans depuis le premier tour de la
présidentielle alain juppé s'était
imposé comme le futur premier ministre
naturel un an et demi avant l'élection
le futur président chirac faisait déjà
l'éloge de son petit protégé
les sentiments que nous éprouvons tous
à l'égard de celui qui est probablement
le meilleur d'entre nous notre
secrétaire général alain juppé
voilà on peut pas faire plus clair
maintenant reste à savoir si le 25e
premier ministre recevra autant
d'honneurs et ben on va devoir patienter
encore un peu merci beaucoup à ça ils
ont raison
vous avez pas de pronostic peut-être il
avait de born this way est bon on va
voir on va patienter passe avoue des
fines sabatier bonsoir donc le
gouvernement lance ce mois ci une
nouvelle appli mobile officiel ça
s'appelle france identité à quoi est-ce
que ça va servir alors à faire face à la
fraude 1 on a un gros problème
d'usurpation d'identité numérique
évidemment fait exploser les ris donc là
on a une nouvelle forme de réponse
proposée par le ministère de l'intérieur
avec cette application va pouvoir enfin
prouvé de manière assez simple son
identité en ligne de manière officielle
je disais mais authentique forte avec un
niveau de sécurité maximal alors pour
quel usage et ben on peut parler par
exemple des démarches en ligne qu'on va
opérer ou encore de demande de
procuration on peut imaginer que ça
serve également à justifier de son
identité par voie numérique auprès de
n'importe quel autre type de service y
compris sur les réseaux sociaux et
éventuellement y compris tout si tu
auras envie en tout cas de s'emparer de
cette application de cette technologie
alors comment ça va fonctionner alors
d'abord la première chose importante à
signaler quand même si ça n'a aucun
caractère obligatoire un tout ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on pourra continuer à
le faire sans cette application
ensuite pour ceux que l'idée séduit va
faudra un peu être patients parce que
dans un premier temps ça va concerner
que quelques français cette application
nécessite d'être détenteur de la
nouvelle carte d'identité donc sa
version biométrique et puis surtout faut
posséder un smartphone qui à la
technologie nfc pour la transmission
sans contact ensuite voilà comment ça se
passe on nous attribue un code à six
chiffres qui permet de créer un compte
et ensuite on peut scanner sa carte
d'identité donc il devient embarqué dans
son smartphone alors il ya un point à
saluer quand même c'est que ça permet de
maîtriser aussi ce qu'on partage avec
les services typiquement on peut
imaginer que les sites adultes s'en sert
pour vérifier la majorité de leurs
utilisateurs on pourra envoyer dans ce
cas que son âge alors attention
toutefois quand même parce que là on a
une version test un qui sort à la fin du
mois ça veut dire ça va être encore en
voie d'amélioration
mais on peut souligner quand même une
des vertus de cette application c'est
qu'elle règle un problème sur lequel ont
bloqué jusqu'ici alors quel est le
problème alors ce problème ça concerne
les informations en fait qui vont être
embarqués dans l'application le décret
précise que l'application va utiliser
les données qui sont contenues dans la
puce électronique donc de la nouvelle
carte nationale d'identité à l'exclusion
de l'image des empreintes digitales
c'est intéressant parce que ça signifie
en fait que le gouvernement
abandonné toute velléité d'utiliser la
reconnaissance biométrique pour vérifier
une identité numérique faut rappeler
quand même que le précédent projet alice
m qui vient donc d'être abrogée reposait
sur la reconnaissance faciale alors
attention sujet hautement brûlant
écoutez il s'agit de toute évidence 20
sujet mais sujet hautement sensible
hautement sensible alors hautement
sensible autrement brûlant hautement
politique il a oscillé entre 10 danses
un geste que beaucoup de français pour
iphone oui mais la reconnaissance
faciale cédric hall explique très bien
donc c'était devant le sénat le 16 mars
c'est un sujet brûlant et d'ailleurs
même cette application dont qui dit ne
pas embarquer de données biométriques un
france identité
elle reste quand même sur ce point de la
numérisation des données d'identité ça
reste un sujet très délicat et je note
quand même que le gouvernement a attendu
la nouvelle mandature pour décréter ce
lancement merci beaucoup d'être finie
sabatier françois jamet crois que vous
vouliez réagir sur ce sujet oui non
simplement pour souligner aller les
enjeux derrière la question la
reconnaissance faciale qui pour le
manque d'une série logiciel reste
interdite dans l'union européenne au nom
notamment de la protection de la vie
privée est aussi une grande hypocrisie
par rapport à ça vous souvenez du salon
milipol celui
mitrailleur dans ce salon il y aussi
toute une série d'entreprises françaises
comme dassault ou un dess qui vendent
des logiciels de reconnaissance faciale
qui sont achetés par les polices
pakistanaise ou chinoises notamment de
manière à identifier des demandeurs
d'asile en situation irrégulière et une
grande hypocrisie à ce que
ces logiciels de reconnaissance faciale
qui sont interdits dans l'union
européenne soit produit par des firmes
françaises vendues dans un salon
français à des polices étrangères pour
l'instant on est effectivement personne
de moratoire merci beaucoup c'est la fin
de cette émission vous retrouverez
myriam en kawa la semaine prochaine
d'ici là moi je vous souhaite un bon
week end rester fidèle à à lcp et passer
une bonne soirée sur notre antenne à
bientôt
[Musique]